hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is time
for the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcasting ah
just checking in on you just checking in
to see how you're doing during this
crazy week oh my god can you believe
what happened i gotta be honest with you
as much as people are always saying like
oh my god what has happened to the world
i can't belie can you this is crazy
did you watch that today isn't that
crazy
can you believe how crazy that was
i'm afraid to look out my window right
this is like when they just watched the
weather channel and they said that
something's been upgraded to a tropical
storm
forget about the [ __ ] show that happened
yesterday
and i have to be honest as much as i
downplay [ __ ] i
i can't even pretend here what i saw
yesterday
i don't even have words for those
uniforms that the miami heat wore
against the boston celtics i have to
tell you
i i thought that the tube went out on my
tv
like i'm old enough to remember when the
tube went out like that's what the
[ __ ] picture looked like
i thought i was losing my eyesight i
mean
i'm not trying to divide the country
here i love the miami vice miami heat
logo
at the center court i thought that was
cool as [ __ ]
i i love miami i love that city
and all of that [ __ ] but they they they
went too far
something needed to give okay if you're
gonna do the miami heat
miami vice thing okay and this isn't a
liberal or a [ __ ] conservative point
here i'm just trying to be
i'm trying to be like right down the
middle here
okay if you're gonna do that
and you're gonna do the baseline floor
you got to go more muted colors
for the team but when the center court
logo
and all around the [ __ ] the the
painted area
into the outer bounds and then you have
the uniforms match
it was um that was a lot to look at
and i have to say that as an american
during a pandemic
i i can't believe how tone deaf the
miami heat
organization is to have them come out
in those uniforms that i just think fly
in the face
okay of everybody who's ever fought for
this country and eventually played in
the nba
and you know if i was the president of
the miami heat right now
i would be calling everybody in my
my publicist wing trying to get some
sort of apology because i feel
as a basketball fan watching the end
that nba game i feel like i'm owed an
apology because i was triggered
okay oh and by the way some jerk-offs
broke into the uh what was it
what is it called the capitol building
[Laughter]
um what i was waiting for was
for cnn or fox news or the huffington
post or any one of these [ __ ]
jerk off phony [ __ ] journalists
nowadays people to accept some of
what their level of responsibility in
fanning the flames that led to that um
and i just want to say once and lastly
once and for all if you watch cnn or if
you watch
fox news to get your news you are a
[ __ ]
jerk off all right you're not watching
the news
okay even when i was a kid you really
weren't watching the news you were
watching
a version of whatever they had censored
who the [ __ ] knows what's going on
but the level that they are taking it to
now
and how much cnn fox news huffington
post all of these [ __ ] people have
divided
the country okay and then all you
mouth breathing morons who go on social
media
and talk about politics and [ __ ]
um you are
adding fuel to the fire that leads to
this [ __ ] and if you're on the left
and you watched what happened yesterday
and you think that that's what somebody
on the right is like that is an example
of the average person on the right
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
the same way if you're on the right and
you look at the left and you see these
[ __ ] idiots
some of these loudmouth hollywood idiots
out here and some of this [ __ ] that
comes out of their mouth that that's
what the average
liberal thinks you're also a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um but that's how the world is now i
haven't said that let's
just have some fun with this here um
i love i only saw a couple of clips
because i had a celtics game to watch
and i realized that 99.9
of of my fellow americans weren't
at the capitol building yesterday so i
have no problems with liberals i have no
problems with conservatives i know
sometimes people don't agree
but i don't look at that yesterday like
those are
you know that those did you see the guy
who clearly went to an army navy a
surplus store
and bought himself a gi joe costume with
and he kept his civilian backpack that
little looking like a fat gi joe going
in with his dumbass helmet
and then you got to give it up to the
[ __ ] guy there with the
the the the buffalo sabre fan there
buffalo bill fan with the big horns i
mean that guy is immediately a legend
and i feel like
he branded himself
for the rest of his life he gets to be
like i'm the guy who sat
where tip o'neil used to nod off and
nancy pelosi and who i don't know
anybody else who's been speaker of the
[ __ ] house
he sat right there and i just feel like
for the rest of his life he can go to
swap meets and sign autographs five
bucks at whack and he's gonna be good
you know and you know the way the
bankers have this thing run i'm happy
for that guy
good for him um other than that i didn't
watch a [ __ ] second of it and uh
you know
[Music]
i got my conservative friends right now
no the footage didn't add up there was
antifa that the [ __ ] idiots live like
who
follow politics i swear to god they're
just like i just texted him i go you
guys you guys are like sports fans
you know what i mean where everybody
just like you see
all the fouls the other teams doing but
you don't see the one that you're doing
it's just [ __ ] i can't
talk to people like that i really i
really
can't you know what i mean it's like the
same [ __ ] [ __ ] who worship obama
and act like he didn't [ __ ] sit there
drone bombing playgrounds and weddings
i mean the guy is a war criminal the
same way george w was they're all
[ __ ] war criminals working for
bankers and oil companies that's what
the [ __ ] they're doing
all right the same people that are
holding obama's feet to the fire
won't hold bush's feet to the fire and
vice versa and then that stupid phone
conversation comes out and all trump
people like well you know there's
context you gotta we gotta hear the
whole conversation
and then people in the liberal like oh
my god how come you don't [ __ ] arrest
this guy
and literally obama could have been on
the phone saying the exact same [ __ ]
thing and the
[ __ ] idiots would flip and i i i
can't deal with it anymore
so what i do is i just lose myself
in old movies and i still watch sports
and that type of thing
so um the latest thing
um somebody told me to watch
uh
somebody told me to watch what the [ __ ]
is it
the um what the hell was it called
it was another one of these art dealer
movies this thing you gotta see it it's
[ __ ]
it's kind of sad
what's really sad is i can't find the
[ __ ] email
not the email the text message i just
had it i just had it
where are you i give up i give up with
these goddamn [ __ ] phones
are you guys afraid to like erase text
threads with people
you know it's almost like you need
evidence in case they [ __ ] go nuts
later on try and claim something okay i
watched this thing called the price of
everything
and it had to do with like the whole art
world and how
they uh come up with the prices of
things and there's this one woman who's
in it that you just have to see
because she's sort of on the business
side of it and she talks so
passionately about these [ __ ]
paintings
and it takes about a third of the movie
in before you realize like she's not
talking about the painting she's talking
about what it's worth
because if you really listen to her
talking about the paintings it's so
[ __ ] surface
and just sort of just saying what she's
heard other people say my favorite thing
that she says
she goes i mean look at this here this
is just a masterpiece and it was like a
little
doc sound dog looked like it was running
the way they'd drawn it she goes look
let me look at that dog i mean that's
the way it's moving i mean that's like a
masterpiece and like i love dogs i have
a dog
like that's what she said about it and
it's just like you don't know [ __ ] about
that painting you don't know why it's
good or why it isn't good you just know
people [ __ ] like it
and it's worth a lot of money so you're
saying it is a [ __ ] masterpiece
but the second people walk away from it
and they're not into that artist anymore
you're gonna walk away too that's kind
of what i learned it was like
i always thought that the music business
was the most [ __ ] brutal
and then just looking at the art world
it's now seeming like
you know it's even worse
where i feel like even like in the music
world
there are bands that are so legit
that they can stay around
and then you have other like people that
go the pop star
boy band root where i feel like painters
all have to deal with the boy band thing
um like i saw in this
one of the documentaries like uh
jean-michel basquiay how the [ __ ] you
say his name
and uh andy warhol got together and made
paintings together
and then they had a showing and they got
completely trashed by the critics
they said they're both washed up and i
guess they're both trying to cling to
each other now
that's what they said and they didn't
sell any paintings
and then in the next year andy died and
the year after that
jean-michel died and now those paintings
that everybody says were [ __ ] are now
worth like 100 million dollars
[Laughter]
so what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] do you do with that what in the
[ __ ] do you do with that and they have
to exist in that goddamn world
um so i don't know if you're into that
type of [ __ ]
uh i will tell you something hilarious
so this person i know that's really into
art and stuff like that which i've
never been into i just never been into
it but i started watching this stuff
and it kind of made me like curious
about it so this person tells me says
you know
here in la they have a museum that has
the biggest collection of
jean-michel basquiat paintings
and the name of the the [ __ ] museum
is is called the broad but it's spelt
b-r-o-a-d
so i said to my wife i was like you know
they got you know when this
[ __ ] pandemic if it ever ends we
should go over you know they got this
the greatest collection in the country
of
jean-michel paintings down the street at
the broad
i called it the broad because that's how
it was written i thought it meant like
broad
like i was like wow that's kind of weird
that you'd call a museum the broad you
know but then i thought well maybe it
means like
they have a broad variety of artists
and my wife laughed at me for like
[ __ ]
10 minutes going it's not the broad
[ __ ] meathead it's the broad
so that just becomes another running
joke in our relationship so
someday you know i'm gonna take her out
to lunch
you know and bring her over to the broad
and i'll look at a bunch of paintings
that i don't understand but what i do
understand is i understand
um the way those painters are treated
you know i get that i'm like oh yeah
this is
this is still show business this is a
little harder hardcore version of this
it's the same old [ __ ] [ __ ] it's
really fascinating though
so anyway plowing ahead my
daughter uh started school this week
and um that was an amazing thing
and uh it was kind of funny both me and
my wife
had different levels of anxiety
about it like when we dropped her off at
school she didn't cry
like some kids were having like
meltdowns i guess or whatever
and my daughter was totally cool we were
like all right
see you later buddy and she goes in
there and as we drive away
you know my wife got emotional and
everything i was like she's gonna be
fine
you know and you know it's just it's a
sad thing because it's it's
it's the beginning of her going out into
the world
you know those first four years of your
kid's life
you know it's weird there's i think when
you're on your exhausted days going oh
god someday they're going to go to
school so at least i'll get a couple
hour break here
but you know you don't want it to end
because they're your little buddy
and when they go to school then it just
kind of like oh man
now this is like you know
she's her world her world has expanded
like tenfold like her whole universe was
hanging here at the house with us so
you know my wife got like emotional and
stuff like that right so
um we're going to go pick her up and it
was really a
big deal for me that we were there
before the kids got let out and i wanted
her to
you know i didn't want her waiting and
all the other kids seeing their parents
i wanted her you know to see that we
were there too
so my wife agrees and then she goes hey
you know i got to get some stuff at the
grocery store
why don't we leave a little bit earlier
and knock it out i said fine just as
long as we're there
at the top of the hour right when we're
supposed to pick her up and she goes
fine
so she goes in the grocery store she
goes off and she texts me
going out [ __ ] you know there's a really
long line here maybe i should lose
tomorrow and i'm like well
you know maybe you should and then i
don't hear from her so she stays in
there and it's like you know whatever
140 145 right and i and it starts
getting
and i'm texting like hello and she's
like sorry i'm almost done
and then at like 1 52 she's like
standing in line
and we're right around the corner but
now i'm sitting there in the car
and i feel like you know we're doing a
bank robbery
and we synchronized our watches and she
was supposed to be out
they've hit the alarm the cops are
coming what the [ __ ] is going on
right so
she's [ __ ] taken forever and finally
at like
1 58 she's like drive around now i have
to drive around cause she's cut it this
[ __ ] close and i'm
at this point like i lose my temper
so i'm driving around and she i see her
come walking out and now i'm in the line
to get back into the [ __ ]
grocery store so i'm beeping the horn
the guy in front of me thinks i'm
beeping at him and i'm beeping my wife
and she's not [ __ ] looking back
i beep like six times then i say [ __ ] it
i drive around the line
now everybody in the line thinks i'm
this impatient douche telling people to
go and i don't wait my turn
i gotta pull up next to her emotions are
heightened it's
it's 159 right she you know she gets in
the car and i was just like yo nia what
the [ __ ] i thought we were gonna [ __ ]
i flipped out so then we get to the
school
and now we're in a fight
and we get out we're standing in line
we're like in a fight and my wife gives
me a dirty look of course because i
yelled at her and then i'm thinking in
my head like
oh this is me this one's on me
you're the one who added the [ __ ]
thing right and i was just like all
right
do i want to be the couple that's
arguing on the first day of school i
don't so i
i did something i never do i just walked
away and i sat in the [ __ ] car
and i breathed a little bit and i was
like all right
okay and we got there they were they
they just let the kids out like one at a
time so they make sure that everybody
goes home with the right parents so
you know in my wife's mind we weren't
late
because that's how they were doing it
but in my mind it's like no we are late
because instead of being you know second
third in line now we're like 10th in
line so then you know if you do that
every [ __ ] day
you know i would think your kid's in
there like how come my parents always
pick me up less i mean it wasn't that
bad but i'm thinking all of this [ __ ] so
whatever she cried at the beginning of
the day i flipped out at the grocery
store so
um
i was like all right i don't want to be
in the car so i get out of the car i
just
stand there and i just said listen i'm
sorry i yelled
i still like you all right i like you a
lot even though you're a jerk so she
kind of [ __ ] smiled and i was like
all right
she's still pissed whatever but we were
in a good enough place
our kid comes out she's all excited she
had a great time thank god so we get in
the [ __ ] car and we're driving home
she tells me she likes all the kids in
class everything's great so it's just it
was [ __ ] perfect right
and then we get home first a day my wife
sort of like [ __ ] pissed me and then
the greatest thing we actually talked
about it at night ironed the whole
[ __ ] thing out
she said why she did what she did she
apologized i said why i did what i did i
apologized
i went back to therapy i was doing that
anyways i talked about it today
and then i talked to her about it again
today and we're
back to being in a great place and
um that is not what i witnessed while i
was growing up
[Laughter]
so um i'm just
telling you guys a story because i know
i'm not you know out alone when
being an angry [ __ ] lunatic um and
what i should have done
is i should have just been like i should
have remained calm and then just stated
like
you know you told me that you were going
to be out by such and such time and now
you're not and now this is making me
feel like a bad parent
um now who's kidding who even if i did
that
she still wouldn't admit it to any
wrongdoing because
she is a woman okay sorry my misogyny is
going to come up a little bit here
but at least i would have given me
firmer ground to stand on but whatever
i'm kind of glad i flipped out because
it's something that i want to stop doing
so um i've decided that i'm just going
to write down
on a piece of paper and fold it in half
just a little book
i can read to start my day
it's gonna be like how do you want your
day to be
do you want to get in a fight with you
you want to yell at your wife get into a
fight
you know do you want to do this do you
want to do that or do you want to do
this
these are your options and it's the
weirdest [ __ ] thing because i always
have those thoughts
and what i kind of realized when you go
to therapy you can have all these
[ __ ] thoughts
and they're just sort of not real until
you say it
and then once you say it you're like oh
[ __ ]
i've said that out loud i don't know
it's weird it's how my brain works so if
i [ __ ] write this [ __ ] down
you know maybe i can i can
i don't know not be such a [ __ ] idiot
i guess i don't know but at the end of
the day you know something
the bar is set really low
and i want to commend all of you who are
listening to this
if you're on the right if you're on the
left gay you're straight whatever the
[ __ ] you do if you like to bang an
animal here or there without anybody
knowing
right i just figure is as long as you
didn't
break into the capitol building with a
buffalo horn on your head
i think you had a good day
[Laughter]
i don't even know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about at this point but the
celtics won three in a row
and my buddy paul verzi uh
is there anything better we're gonna be
starting this sports podcast joking
around and [ __ ]
um later on this month his new york
knicks
won three in a row three in a [ __ ]
row
it's gonna be a great podcast a boston
guy oh suburbs of boston and a new york
guy
um so we got all the sports [ __ ] and all
of that and
i lean a little bit left he leans a
little right it's [ __ ] great it's
perfect it's going to be a lot of fun
and
you know these podcasts i do like the
one i do with bert kreischer
and now it's going to do one with paul
verzier just becoming my way of hanging
out with my stand-up friends that i miss
to be honest with you um all right
here we go uh oh jesus christ listen to
this [ __ ]
this is this is a new advertiser this is
amazing and i have to do this
even though it's slightly disgusting uh
okay i think it's called viomi vio me
it's these [ __ ] companies they always
have these [ __ ] goddamn names i can
never figure
v-i-o-m-e
[Music]
viome helps you take control of your
health so you can improve your energy
gut health and boost your immune system
i mean how perfect is this right now
listen to this [ __ ]
viome's award-winning at-home tests
decode your cellular
okay what the [ __ ] word is that my my
toe
oh oh my god mitochondrial i think i
remember that from biology class way
back in the day
uh and i never took biology class the
[ __ ] am i oh i did
junior high that was like biology light
and microbiome sorry
mycobiomy health giving you powerful
insight with over 30 health scores
via me gives you a precise
whole food nutrition plan and precision
supplements based on your unique
biological needs yeah cause you know
that dumb [ __ ] where you see
you know you gotta stop eating bananas
and that other idiot going you know you
could run three miles a day on a [ __ ]
treadmill seven days a week
you ain't gonna lose any weight that
doesn't work that's never worked
the [ __ ] are you talking about i'm
almost gonna run a marathon every week
and i'm not gonna lose
weight the [ __ ] i'm not i'm totally am
unless i get off and eat a [ __ ] whole
box oreo cookies
sorry wyomi partners include
the mayo clinic gsk and others and is
used by olympic gold
medalists and elite professional
athletes yeah i heard like the golden
state warriors do this
uh go to viomi.com and learn how you can
get your unique insights for better
health and wellness
now here's a good thing you don't have
to give them your real name
okay but the weird thing is i believe
you have to [ __ ] into an envelope and
mail it to him some
something like that okay but if steph
curry can [ __ ] into a [ __ ] envelope
so can you
uh use the promo code burr at checkout
to save ten dollars on your first
purchase and 55 percent off all
subscription products that's viomi.com
promo codeberg v-i-o-m-e dot com
promo code bur i'm gonna do this with my
wife they
i believe this is the company they look
at a stool sample jesus christ
i mean how do you send [ __ ] through the
mail and you're not on the fbi's [ __ ]
i mean that sounds like
you're going to be is that like a
terrorist act
post 9 11. um you
do this and then they figure out your
body
like dna like makeup or whatever and
then like what foods
you should be eating versus somebody
else
and it just seems like a way to keep
your joints from getting inflamed by
eating the wrong stuff
or having you know me with my [ __ ] belly
here you know i'm trying to get rid of
um it just seems like it's perfect and
there might be something that you were
eating like uh
my buddy who did this was telling me
he's like i used to always eat rice
with fish because they always saw that
that's what you're supposed to have and
it turns out i shouldn't be having that
i should actually be having a potato and
i always say potatoes are bed
they do [ __ ] like that you can figure it
out
okay and this is why these guys are
great because if you know what the [ __ ]
you're supposed to eat
that is 90 of the battle for living
longer
living healthy and keeping your your
weight off and then you don't have to
buy some stupid mirror mirror on the
[ __ ] wall
gym thing do you ever wonder why they
just keep coming up with new workouts
and they keep coming out with new
[ __ ]
the peloton oh let me go ride the tour
de france every month and you still see
all these
fat [ __ ] walking around it's because
those things are only 10 percent of 10
of staying in shape the other 90 is is
eating
all right and these [ __ ] guys are
going to help you out
viomi.com promo code burr
[ __ ] an envelope and get abs tomorrow
[ __ ] an envelope today get abs
tomorrow there we go all right helix
everybody
you know i know some of you are sleeping
on saggy old mattresses at night you
deserve better than that
so give yourself an upgrade helix sleep
has a quiz that takes just two minutes
to complete and matches your body type
and sleep preference to the perfect
mattress for you
and you know what you do with your old
mattress you take it down to skid row
and give it to a bum
not a bum a homeless guy sorry old
school name uh why
give it down there to one of them
[ __ ] winos uh why would you buy a
mattress made for someone else with
helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
uh that doesn't mean you're interesting
all right that just means your shoulders
a little weirder than mine
uh so they have several different
mattresses models to choose from
they have soft medium and firm no so
they didn't say hard
mattresses mattresses great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot
and jesus christ would you kill a hooker
[ __ ] sleeping hot
even if a helix plus mattress uh they
even have it for plus
size folks look at that you're [ __ ]
an envelope and then you can get a
smaller [ __ ] mattress
um it's been awesome getting messages
from so many of you who also find helix
mattress
the helix mattress of your dreams so if
you're looking for a mattress you take
the quiz you order the mattress that's
you match to and the mattress comes
right to your door it's shipped for free
you don't even need to go to a mattress
store ever again helix is awesome but
you don't need to take my word for it
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
uh and by gq and wired magazine just go
to helixsleep.com
take the two minute quiz and they'll
match you to a customized mattress that
will give you
the best sleep of your life they have a
10-year warranty and you get to try it
out 100 nights for risk-free
they'll even pick it up if you don't
love it gross but you will
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's awesome
um i'll tell you when you get married
you know like in baseball and all these
things they have like a salary cap they
need to have like a throw pillow cap
for women the amount that they can
[ __ ] throw on a goddamn couch
um what is it why do they love the
pillows i don't know why do they love it
i don't know
why do we love seeing dogs playing poker
why do we love seeing that i don't know
i guess we're all weird
all right roman please use one of the
intros below or we encourage you to add
lib based on your experience with roman
items highlighted in yellow are
mandatory to read verbatim
okay great now that we're all in this i
see this full disclosure on this podcast
all right i'm going to read number one
i'm going to go with number one
you know it can be awkward or
embarrassing to talk about erectile
[ __ ] that okay if your dick doesn't work
you you
look that doctor in the eye you talk
about your wet noodle
i'm reading number two how often do you
use the excuse like
i had a long day at work or i'm just not
feeling it
i've used that it's easy to talk about
erectile dysfunction
is i'm too tired to [ __ ] the same thing
as erectile dysfunction
or if you're saying you're tired but
you're not that's erectile dysfunction
anyway but roman makes it easy to
discuss
and treat e.d uh with roman you can get
a free online of value
evaluation and ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction
all from the comfort and privacy of your
home
a healthcare professional will work with
you
to find the best treatment plan if
medication if medication is appropriate
roman will ship the you real medicine
with free
two-day shipping the whole process is
straightforward simple and discreet
so it doesn't say here's your ed
medicine on the outside of the box if
you're wondering
uh getting started is simple just go to
get roman r-o-m-a-n-dot-com
and complete an online visit erectile
dysfunction
used to be tough to talk about but now
there's roman complete an online visit
to connect with the doctor and take care
of it isn't it ridiculous in 2021 you
can't just say listen man
my dick isn't working there's something
wrong with it the blood's not going into
it what do you got for me here
all right i'm a man i want to [ __ ] can
you help me out doc
just go to getroman.com to get 15
off your first order of ed treatment
erectile dysfunction
and a free online visit and free two-day
shipping that's getroman.com for 15
off your first order of erectile
dysfunction treatment
get roman.com today
all right
doc you got to help me what seems to be
a problem you know my dick
looks like a fat guy in an airplane
nodding off in coach
except it doesn't keep popping its head
up waking up it just sort of keels over
it looks like it's getting in crash
position it's putting its heads
between its knees and the knees meaning
my balls can you [ __ ] do something
about this please
you smockwear and [ __ ] um
you know you could say something like
that you know add a little color to it
there's nothing wrong with that all
right that's it okay this is bill burr i
respect you if you're conservative i
respect you
if you're [ __ ] liberal i respect
whatever the [ __ ] it is you're doing
all right that's it okay
everybody let's [ __ ] calm down all
right if you're not a doctor don't say
doctor [ __ ]
listen to doctors can we do that in 2021
stop acting like you're a doctor because
you have a laptop can we [ __ ] do that
stop acting like you're in the cia
because you you went to a couple of
websites online
i mean i've been guilty all of this [ __ ]
but i just figured i'd give you a
lecture everybody else likes to
pontificate why why can't i
all right and if elected all right
please enjoy the music
picked out by the wonderful andrew
themeless
and i will be um
what am i going to be doing i'll be
watching the playoffs this weekend oh
you got the uh what do we got we got the
titans and the ravens
the titans versus the ravens 200 000
yard
running back oh derek henry
ryan tanner hill versus
lamar johnson you know whoever
else plays on the [ __ ] ravens i don't
know anybody's name anymore
i'm looking forward to that and i'm
gonna watch the games
probably later than the third round
because i probably have some dad [ __ ] to
do this weekend which i'm really getting
into
um in a pandemic kind of way because i
was doing this great thing where we were
going to mom and pop restaurants those
are my favorite places to take the
family out to dinner
all right i don't want to go out to some
dumbass applebee's
i want to be at some place that you know
we've been here for 40 [ __ ] years
making these goddamn sandwiches
you know you go there and there's like
family working behind the counter i love
those places
so uh it sucks that you can't go out to
them now because
uh one in five baby five and one
uh people have covet out here in l.a
because they just [ __ ] categorically
[ __ ] refuse
you know why because too many of them
were [ __ ] [ __ ] over the [ __ ]
holidays
right then they had to go breathe all
over her now she's gone
um
[Music]
god bless these doctors god bless these
doctors you know what we're such [ __ ]
dopes regular people
you know what they should do when they
finally get this vaccine for everybody
they should put us on like you know
remember back in the day when you had
that little gun at the carnival and you
had to shoot those ducks going that's
what they should do
but people didn't wear [ __ ] masks
they should just [ __ ] shoot it right
into that goddamn neck
um for the rest of us all right that's
it go [ __ ] yourselves
have a great weekend and i'll check in
on you no no i'll talk to you on monday
okay that's it
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday january 7th
2013 the first monday of a wonderful new
year
we're we're in our teens everybody
in this century has anybody said
basically what this cent uh this decade
is called by the way
is this the teens i guess you can
officially say that right
i mean they say that about the 1900s
right they say that well it was the
roaring 20s
they always blow off the first two the
arts
the teens the 30s the 40s i don't
[ __ ] know anyways
you're not gonna believe this [ __ ] i'm
sitting here right
wake up i don't have anything to talk
about today
um so i was like i know i know what i'll
do i'll go check out the [ __ ]
eggheads
over at ted.com see what the [ __ ]
they're up to and what do i see
this is why we're going to be extinct
quicker than global warming or
quicker than anything else you could
ever come up with one of the things
right on the front page
is this guy hayden perry and you know
what he's talking about everybody
he's talking about re-engineering
mosquitoes
to fight disease
how can these people be so smart and so
[ __ ] stupid
all at the same time
do you really think that you're just
gonna re-engineer like well i don't know
what they're going to do like take the
old engine out and put something better
in there that works for us
the guy starts it off of course is
always with you know something really
ominous he's like and forgive my awful
whatever british accent here but it
comes out he's just like today we're
going to talk about
the most dangerous animal on the planet
for humans now most of you probably
think that that's a tiger
maybe it's a lion i'm actually talking
about the mosquito
the mosquito has killed more people than
plagues
war aids and he goes on this whole
[ __ ] thing
okay and he's going on and on about how
mosquitoes
have killed a bunch of [ __ ] people
you know throughout the course of
history which if you [ __ ] think about
it is is really
not that mind-blowing you know
plagues come and go wars begin and
end but mosquitoes they never quit
every [ __ ] day they're biting people
you know what i mean they're like that
dude that always goes to the gym
he doesn't take six months off and
eating [ __ ] moon pies
and then come back with this big doughy
stomach like me
the [ __ ] mosquito is relentless
all right so then he's just sitting
there going now you know the mosquito
it only travels only 200 yards in its
entire [ __ ] life and blah blah blah
blah
but basically it lays eggs and [ __ ] you
know water and that type of crap and
then you know we're [ __ ] we go all
over the [ __ ] world and we got the
eggs with us
and they say you know the mosquitoes are
all over the [ __ ] planet
as they should be biting people
killing people giving us some [ __ ]
elbow room
this [ __ ] jackass and his [ __ ]
egghead friends
want to re-engineer one of the few
things that is keeping the human
population
just vaguely in check which it isn't
we're up to seven billion people and
this [ __ ] [ __ ] wants to
re-engineer mosquitoes to fight disease
rather than to spread it
do you understand how [ __ ] up this guy
is like it's like a form of terrorism
i i don't know i know you guys think i'm
a [ __ ] but like
there's a reason why mosquitoes kill
people
you know there's a reason there's a
reason everything kind of kills
everybody it just
keeps it balanced this [ __ ] jerk off
do you really think you're just gonna
rewire these [ __ ] mosquitoes and then
that's gonna that's not gonna have a
domino effect and
i don't you know what it's like listen
to these [ __ ] guys it's like
listening to some weekend warrior
who decides he's gonna rewire his house
and you know within three years he's
gonna [ __ ] burn it down
because he doesn't have he's he's not a
licensed electrician
that's what these guys are okay
they're so [ __ ] smart they're gonna
re-engineer a mosquito but like
how's that gonna affect the [ __ ] uh
god give me a give me an animal a bird
kind of [ __ ] it's gonna affect
something
i'm someone over my head over this but i
know i'm right
i know i'm right you can't just you
can't just if you [ __ ] re-engineer
that thing to help us
okay it won't it's not now it can't kill
us
he's talking about this did uh the [ __ ]
did he call it
dengue disease dengue disease or some
[ __ ] that evidently
it is killing a bunch of people first
time you get it you feel like you have a
fever
and you can actually have the feeling
like your bones are going to break they
actually call it
break bone fever and uh you develop like
antibodies but there's three strains and
then when you get the next one i mean
just it's like a horror movie but a
necessary one
you know these [ __ ] nerds
ever think that there's a reason
that mosquitoes kill people that's what
i i i love about nature is is it all
makes sense
you know if you just remove your
emotions from it
and you just look at the whole thing as
like a uh
i don't know like a math problem no ggs
right but where where we have you got
way too much
it's like if you open the cupboard you
know what i mean you'd have like [ __ ]
like one fig newton and then seven
billion pounds of flour
i think that they should re-en not not
re-engineered they just let the [ __ ]
mosquitoes kill people if you get killed
i'm sorry you know but you're dead it's
over you're out of the way
and we continue on and there's apples
for everybody
you know we're already growing salmon
and dishes man-made [ __ ] salmon
we're literally [ __ ] with the food
supply another form of terrorism
so he just comes in and poisons the food
supply you know
if you have like a [ __ ] mask on you
know and some sort of uh bath towel
on you on your head or whatever then
that's all oh yeah that's a terrorist
that's a terrorist but if you got a
[ __ ] lab coat on
you know you're putting all these
pesticides in there in that type i don't
[ __ ] i'm i'm on my soapbox this week
people
standing up on that box letting
everybody hear my ignorance
hayden perry if for some reason i don't
know why
you felt like being dumb this week and
you're listening to this podcast can you
please not read
can you and your friends please not
re-engineer mosquitoes
can you just let them do their [ __ ]
job
you know why don't you do the world a
favor and stick your head in a mosquito
nest why don't you [ __ ] do that
this is like mad scientist [ __ ]
ted.com is the scariest [ __ ] website
out there these [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know on their reengineering
mosquitoes and they're building robots
that know everything
that can run like barry sanders you know
and like
like that's not gonna be a bad thing
hayden perry
you know what it is his heart is in the
right place
he sees death he sees suffering he sees
pain
and he wants to [ __ ] stop it
all right because what he's doing is
he's chasing
the myth of a utopia
the myth of utopia is that if you lived
in a utopia
everybody would be happy all the time
and nothing bad would ever happen
and that's just not the case because of
the emotion of boredom
if everything was awesome all the
[ __ ] time you would go out of your
[ __ ] mind because every day would be
the exact same
it would just be awesome hey it's
lunchtime you have a turkey sandwich
isn't this the greatest jerk you say yes
every day it's the greatest [ __ ]
sandwich ever
every [ __ ] day exhausted
with happiness it would be exhausting
you know what i mean you gotta have
people getting bit by mosquitoes
dying if that doesn't happen you can't
enjoy the super bowl at the same level
you know what i mean you can't enjoy
just sitting there having a turkey
sandwich because you can't you don't
have the thing to be like well at least
you know i'm eating a turkey sandwich
the meat's a little dry but hey at least
i didn't get
bit by a [ __ ] mosquito and die you
know laying
face down in a puddle of eggs
if you eliminate all of that i mean i
don't what are you supposed to [ __ ]
do
there's all these these all these
there's all these myths
that if we just did this people would
get along if we just did that people get
along
i don't think we would i think
boredom boredom is at the basis
of of i don't know that that's what
drives us
i don't know you just want to do
something else being competitive and all
it just you wouldn't get rid of that
just imagine that if you lived in a
[ __ ] utopia everybody had the best
car everybody drives a [ __ ] bentley
everybody's got the greatest [ __ ]
stereo everybody's got a victoria's
secret [ __ ]
model everybody's got you know out on an
infinity pool
everybody's got it okay now
that if you could just snap your fingers
and make that happen that would be
probably the most insane
five-day straight party the world has
ever seen
but after five [ __ ] days you'd get
you'd get sick of it
i think you would nobody ever stubs
their toe
nobody ever falls down you just you know
i don't know re-engineering [ __ ]
mosquitoes
you know i saw a transestite do a
[ __ ] face plant
this week and it coming out of a donut
shop
first of all in la there's donut shops i
swear to god
there's like 19 chains of of of donut
shops out here
they're on like every other block i
don't get it
everybody out here that i know is in
this business
and you're trying to stay remotely in
shape so you you limit
your [ __ ] twitter bashing or the the
level that you get bashed on twitter
i don't know who's eating all the
[ __ ] donuts this is who
um but they're everywhere
so i'm [ __ ] cutting down uh
oh no i was on fountain ave i really
shouldn't give this street up but
fountain ave
is the one for you taurus out here when
you want to go east to west or west to
east
and it's during rush hour don't take
don't take [ __ ] sunset don't take
santa monica
take fountain it's right in the middle
but on one of those strips there
there's this place uh yum yum donuts i
believe is what it's called
or is that santa mark i can't remember
so anyway it's a [ __ ] donut shop and
they got this stupid little like
you know like those chains you know they
put like poles down and then they they
tie a chain to it
those little things and it kind of
droops down and goes over so this
[ __ ] dude woman right was stepping
over it and
he had a thing of donuts and just fell
down on the ground
now normally i would laugh a guy in a
dress
fell face-first with a [ __ ] handful
of donuts i mean that's pretty much
you're going right down the checklist
of a home run when it comes to comedy
but the dude
fell so effeminately i felt bad
like the gentleman in me was like oh
that lady guy
the lady just fell and the way the dude
put his hand up it was just it ended up
just being really sad
you know but i i pride myself i'll pat
myself on the back here
me and my ego that i resisted the urge
of taking out my phone and filming it
you know i don't like that [ __ ] now how
every [ __ ] moment becomes this
uh i don't know what to call it
i don't like how uh humiliation
never ends now you know these poor kids
coming up it's just like somebody gets
kicked in the balls they get shot with a
[ __ ] bb
gun and his dick somebody films it
omg epic failed dick bb [ __ ] video
and then it's just on the internet
forever
and the guy's 35 years old he's got a
drinking problem
and he's looking at this girl he feels
sparks for the first time in years
he goes to talk to her and right as
things are going good somebody yells ah
that's the death [ __ ] epic failed
dick bibi guy
she's like oh my god is that you i
remember that
didn't a chunk of your helmet get taken
off what the [ __ ] right
it just never no humiliation never ends
never [ __ ] ends i don't know what i'm
talking about this week
does it matter i don't think it matters
this week because hayden perry is going
to re-end your mosquitoes to fight
disease
okay you're going to rewire them are you
going to rewire everything else on the
[ __ ] planet
so it's all compatible are you just
going to [ __ ] with that hayden
i don't get it you know what it is this
guy
i don't even think he [ __ ] believes
in it he is he i bet he's corporate
owned
he's corporate owned this is what
they're going to do
they're going to own the re-engineered
mosquitoes
okay and that when they bite you they
make you stronger
and then they also they go out and they
choke out all the other
mosquitoes but you can only get them
from them
and then what they do on the back side
is they make the regular ones that
aren't
re-engineered they re-injure near them
to make them even more lethal
all right because that way you know the
way mosquitoes reproduce
it's just like this entrance and
everybody's going to want to buy your
mosquitoes
you know it'll be this endless
supply and endless demand for the supply
that you can just [ __ ] they're like
rabbits
right i mean so this all makes sense to
me
what the [ __ ] am i 15 minutes in jesus
it's getting deep this week
um all right let's do a little
advertising here and then i'll tell you
about story about a rabbit
i think it's gonna be all animals this
week um the [ __ ] is it
[Music]
all right um
stamps.com everybody uh one great
resolution you can make for this new
year
maximize every minute and every dollar
for your small business i know an easy
way to do that with stamps dot com
think about how much time you've wasted
going to the post office how much money
you've wasted
leasing an expensive postage meter
uh stamps dot com is the is the better
way to get postage
just use what you already have your own
computer and your printer to buy and
print official us postage for any letter
or package
with stamps.com everything you would do
at the post office you can do right from
your own desk
and at a fraction of the cost of a
postage meter
um i've used stamps.com for the last i
don't know
when did i start reading these about a
year ago about a year ago
i send all my dvds out to the clubs it's
phenomenal i used to have to go down to
the post office
or go to one of those mailboxes cetera
standing there with these two big stupid
boxes
actually three wondering if i was going
to come home with one trying to do the
math
standing in line behind some lady right
i don't have to do that anymore i just
grab a box bing bang boom put it on this
put it on the uh scale and i'm done
right now get this special offer when
you use my last name bur burr for a no
risk trial
plus 110 bonus offer includes a digital
scale and up to 55 dollars free postage
55 bucks right in your pocket to begin
the new year don't wait go to stamps.com
before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur
b-u-r-r that stamp stop com enter bur
all right back to the podcast so last
night i'm doing this stand-up show
i'm doing a show where i stand up and um
you know i'm trying to find a parking
spot and i do
i'm gonna take you through every like my
new [ __ ] painful detail of this
you know i put in reverse i look in the
camera and i realize i'm a little bit in
the red
so i pull it up a little bit but then
there's a mustang in front of me an old
one looks like a 67 or a 68 and i'm like
i want
this guy to feel like i don't respect
his car so i backed up a little bit more
realizing that i'm mostly in the
unpainted area
so i guess legally i'm okay
so then i decide to get out the driver's
side door okay i lead with my left leg
rather than swinging my right over
um sorry i get out of the [ __ ] car
and i'm walking up the street
you know i'm trying to think what i'm
going to talk about when i go on stage i
look over and there's this [ __ ]
rabbit
sitting outside this apartment a rabbit
this isn't a wild rabbit
this is a domesticated rabbit why do i
know
because it's not afraid of me it's just
sitting there looking at me like you
know
hey what's going on like it's just
chilling on the porch and it's fat
it's a fat [ __ ] rabbit like you know
it's eating human food
rather than uh they held rabbits eat
what do they eat hate carrots at least
the cartoon ones do
do they eat it's carrots
just a bunch of carrots in the wild
lettuce grass i don't know what the [ __ ]
they eat
squirrels i bet they'll find that out
one day
that they actually every once in a while
eat squirrels like you know for the
longest time when they thought like
chimpanzees were vegetarians
and then they found out that every once
in a while they go on a hunt and they
kill a monkey
[ __ ] chimpanzees i hate them i hate
those [ __ ]
okay [ __ ] mosquitoes oh you bite me and
i get a fever
i get a rash and i feel like my bones
are gonna break and then i
you know i'm hot i'm cold i'm hot i'm
dead it's over all right
i would much rather have that than to
have some
[ __ ] roided out fire plug jump on me
rip my face off pull my nuts off and
twist my foot off i would
much rather even though i'm gonna bleed
out quicker than going through the hell
of the dengue death whatever the [ __ ] it
is i would rather go through that
oh my god those [ __ ] creepy long
chimp fingers
you know [ __ ] grabbing right under
your chin
like you're some mass wrestler and he's
gonna reveal your identity
just [ __ ] rips your goddamn face back
oh my god oh [ __ ] i forgot this
i forgot this i gotta look this up right
now you know what i was in uh new mexico
recently
um visiting a high school friend
and uh hang on a second
the [ __ ] was her name and i was in this
this restaurant what is it bronco
boozer
i can't remember a [ __ ] name god damn
it bill you
stink i'm in this italian restaurant
right and they got all these [ __ ]
uh there it is
gina bronco boozer so they got all these
italians on the wall like the old ones
you've always heard frank sinatra and
all the all tito puente you know all the
big italians
latino i don't give a [ __ ] um
all the classic ones you've heard of um
who's the girl there was staring at the
other girl she was trying to be the hot
[ __ ] and then the other girl's [ __ ]
tits were hanging out even more she's
giving them a cycle sophia loren
sophia rent you know all these italians
right beautiful people right
and then they just had some uh obscure
ones
so i see one
and it's it's this woman in tights
and her knee her name is gina bronco
uh boozer and i start reading the story
and basically she was a female wrestler
hugely [ __ ] popular and uh
her big thing was how she got into
wrestling she was like five foot five
like 210 pounds
okay we're talking fourth and goal here
low center of gravity she puts that show
iron head hayward
with the [ __ ] okay that's disgusting
but it's true
so anyways her big claim to fame was
that she choked a [ __ ] cow to death
with her thighs
now to me that just sounds like some
vaudeville like step right up step right
up see the woman to
jump the car to death with if you could
survive for one minute
we will give you this anvil or whatever
the [ __ ] you won back then
um but anyways that was her claim to
fame to get into uh
into wrestling so she went around
barnstorming around the country
and she won all these matches and she
became hugely popular big time fan
favorite and she would do all these
benefits
for charity and whatnot
so one day this is how little we knew
about animals back then they decided to
raise money for charity
that they would have gino bronco boozer
wrestle an old baboon from the zoo
old toothless baboon it didn't have its
teeth now if you never seen anything on
baboons
like baboons have teeth like a [ __ ]
lion there would you ever see one yawn
they can just stop staring
at their rainbow book club ass and just
look at
its [ __ ] teeth i mean this thing
could literally bite your [ __ ] head
off but the
baboon was old and it didn't have any
teeth what could go wrong
so they bring the [ __ ] baboon down i
don't know if i had a little silk
wardrobe
or what you know robe like [ __ ]
greg the hammer valentine who knows i
don't know what it had maybe had his
monkey hair all [ __ ] slicked back and
died platinum
i don't know what but it's gonna but
gina's gonna wrestle this thing so gene
is already in the [ __ ] ring this
whole story is is on the wall at the
restaurant i
i can't believe i didn't take a picture
of it because there's really
very little about this on the internet
so
she's [ __ ] waiting they take a banana
they put it on the stool in the ring
okay now the monk the baboon old
toothless baboons in the ring with this
gina bronco boozer
b-o-u-z-a if you're trying to look it up
and i don't know what happened she
starts i don't know made some sort of
aggressive move towards the [ __ ]
baboon the baboon jumps on her and just
snaps her neck and she's dead within the
first [ __ ] five seconds of the match
and the promoter was like oh my god he's
freaking out
saying something ridiculous like
um basically how how would i know that
that would have happened
how would you know that that would have
happened well well
baboons have the strength of like what
five men
you know i don't know if you've noticed
baboons don't really like
you know you don't ring a bell and then
they stop that's the end of the round
baboon you know they if you start
tapping out like
all right you got me you got me you know
this is turning your head around all
right
all right you know
it doesn't it's not stopping you can't
tap out with a baboon
baboons do not have a [ __ ] what a 10
minute time limit then
they don't fight like that they have a
fight to the death
all right you're coming in there trying
to raise money for emphysema
that thing's coming in there like all
right [ __ ] blood sport here i don't
have any teeth
what's the next thing i'm doing i'm
gonna [ __ ] turn your head around like
the exorcist even though i never saw the
movie and even if i did i don't even
know if it would register
you know dude
cheaters are a fader are afraid of
baboons
but baboon comes over like get the [ __ ]
out of my territory
cheetahs for the most part are like or
leopards maybe it's even a leopard an
even bigger cat
i don't know what i don't know but um
i will tell you to look up the story of
gina bronco boozer
but there's really nothing on here other
than in that restaurant they kind of had
the whole [ __ ] story if i ever go out
to new mexico again
i'm going to go to it's an italian
restaurant
or if somebody lives out there jesus
christ why don't you use technology
please
take a picture of the story it's on the
wall and please send it to me and we'll
put it up on the podcast page because
it's
[ __ ] unreal you know what's funny was
when i read it all i thought about
was this is like this is something like
[ __ ] joe rogan
you know i should have sent the story to
him he could have done a [ __ ] hour of
this on on his podcast with all his
knowledge of animals and ultimate
fighting
who the [ __ ] would get into a goddamn
ring
who the [ __ ] would get into a ring with
the with a baboon like
i guess you know there really there was
no discovery channel
and that's the honest thing like i
wouldn't know anything about i would
know anything about baboons if it wasn't
for basic cable
you know and i wouldn't have known that
that woman got her face [ __ ] ripped
off
if it wasn't for the you know the
instant news [ __ ]
i wouldn't know anything all i would
know about would be the guy up the
street with [ __ ]
seven toes i would just know that
country [ __ ]
but anyways if you get a chance you know
look it up there isn't much information
on it but um
so there you go it's been all about
animals so far hasn't it
the animal podcast oh anyway so i'm
sitting there looking at this fat
[ __ ] rabbit
and it's just sitting there and it was
nighttime i i it really disturbed me
the way it was just sitting there not
looking out for coyotes
not looking out for a house cat i
actually played out in my head this
awful scenario
of a cat slowly coming up to it stalking
it
you know and the rabbit looking right at
the cat and the cat having this weird
sort of
this [ __ ] sees me doesn't he you
know
the lovely nia everybody so i'm telling
this story i saw this rabbit sitting
outside a house last night
a house rabbit a fat i've been eating
fruit loops at the dining room table
house wrap and it just really disturbed
me because it didn't know any better it
didn't know
to be scared it wasn't scared of me it
wasn't looking aren't [ __ ]
yes that's what i'm saying it's
domesticated would you come down here to
get on the podcast
maybe we'll grab yourself a microphone
there lady you got to plug yourself
in so anyways i uh the cords are over
there
we've been through this i'd hit pause on
this thing but i don't know how to do it
and it always ends up shutting off and
then i have to splice it together and
then something happens where
uh um i don't know so anyways
hey you guys have you ever uh you ever
go to make a pot roast in a dutch oven
and in the middle of it you just start
drinking beers and you're about four
beers in
and you can't remember what time you put
the pot roast in that's what the [ __ ] i
did yesterday
i'm so embarrassed i made i made a tough
pot roast
there we go and she's putting on the
windscreen everybody and
bam she's in she's in
hello hey did you try any of the pot
roast
are you still on your diet i i did try
some pot roast but i am still on my diet
even though
it did fall off a little bit i'm back on
it for the next
well for a while but yeah in the middle
of the pot roast it
tasted all right right the outside got a
little tough yeah
well that's what you get for you know i
don't understand
when people when people cook these
beautiful meals that you've been cooking
lately and they have been beautiful
meals mind you
you know yeah you have a nice glass of
wine it's like the whole process
nobody slams four budweisers in a row
while making these beautiful restaurant
quality meals that's a whole
yeah you know what it was stumbling
around the kitchen like oh what time did
i put it in him
oh i [ __ ] it up oh i turned the wrong
burner
i did that i was supposed to i was
trying to turn up the heat for the
potatoes
and i had the uh the roast on simmer
yeah and i turned up the the roast one
hi you know sitting like why isn't these
[ __ ] potatoes it doesn't even look
like it's getting hot and then all of a
sudden i heard my
uh my oh juice sauce going home no juice
i'm bubbling over there yeah i [ __ ]
the whole thing well you know what it
was my ocd kicked in
i had all those budweisers left over
from the rose bowl
and uh are they just taking up space
you don't have ocd you have a dd
i like how you you like oh i have ocd
that's why i had to drink all those
beers
well let me explain it
obsessive-compulsive this is why
essentially well doesn't stand for
obsessive-compulsive drinking
no listen stands for disorder
hey no i i had the uh
i just we had like [ __ ] 12 we brought
so much beer i had like like
15 budweisers in there okay it's taken
up all that space
so i'm thinking if i drink one a day you
know i'll knock this out
in half a month then i go what if i have
two i knock it out in seven
and then i was just like you know i had
him in stacks of two
and i was just like you know i knocked
out two and then i had my third one and
i'm like well the other one's still
sitting there taking up that space
so knock that one out you could have put
them on the bottom shelf like way in the
back though
there's there's ways you could have hey
i could have just wanted to drink them
all
i could have bought a bigger fridge i
could have bought a bigger fridge
rose ball was awesome this year we did
have a tragedy though and i ca i can't
name the name
but somebody got a little too drunk was
walking towards the state i don't know
what happened
what always happens every year is we get
absolutely [ __ ] hammered
and then we all just all of a sudden we
just notice we're the only ones in the
parking lot and then that's when it
clicks that the game's about ready to
start
so then we are the golf course which is
the parking lot and we um
we just walk into the stadium sort of
together and then get separated and then
come back together again like a band
that worked out its differences
you know and when we got to our seats
only three of us made it and there was
some other guy
no i remember what's his face was saying
yes so and so lost his ticket
oh i get the [ __ ] out of here and they
didn't get in and then some other
douchebag comes up and sits in my
buddy's seat where like three drunk
angry guys where the [ __ ] you get that
dick it he's like i bought it
but at first he said he bought it for 25
bucks then then he told somebody else he
bought it for 50.
he either pickpocketed the thing or he
found it on the [ __ ] ground but at
the end of the day it's um
you know it's on my buddy he got too
hammered that's why i always buy the
ticket holder
every year it's like you know when you
put a toddler on a leash
so it can't run away from you that's
that's what i do i put the ticket in
there
put it around my neck and then i
commence drinking
like i'm still oh that's a good idea so
it just stays there stays there you
don't have a problem
i feel your neck getting tugged you know
somebody's trying to steal it right
you know you could even put it like
underneath your shirt if you were
worried about people you know
getting funny ideas yeah but i'd get so
drunk i would think i lost it i'd be
like where is it
where is it i can't breathe
um so anyway no we had a great time
though
you were getting jealous when you saw
all that food that we were cooking
[ __ ]
did the did the ribs up yeah you guys
throw down like it's
it's some sort of like food tailgating
competition
you know it's like this did you tell
them did you tell your podcast listeners
what was on the menu
this extensive tailgating menu oh we had
uh
short ribs wait start at the beginning
what is the beginning
all right breakfast 9 000 [ __ ]
budweisers oh we had breakfast with uh
lamb sausage we got this great butcher
in my neighborhood so we went over there
and literally put in an order that we
had to pick up two days later
a lot of animals died on this day people
we had lamb
but you were very organized about it
it's not like you just went to ralph's
and just grabbed a bunch of cheap meat
like you went to the butcher
the best pretty much the only butcher in
our neighborhood yeah
and put it in order so you had lamb
sausage
goat cheese and roast pepper yeah um
right so that was breakfast okay and
it's not that's the greatest omelet i
have every year
yeah sitting there i got a rose bowl
ticket around my neck
i'm on my beer in my hand exactly and an
omelet in my mouth
i know all that guy [ __ ] that is just
lampooned now it's just [ __ ]
considered silly
if you enjoy that like this is america
it is
it's [ __ ] great and until you've had
a [ __ ] omelet
on new year's day on a golf course
outside the rose bowl go [ __ ] yourself
it was tremendous and then what's his
face we had uh
we had kobe beef uh hot dogs which i
just found out kobe beef the reason why
it's so soft is they treat it like veal
so i gotta be done with that [ __ ] now oh
so now you're not gonna
you're not gonna eat that anymore yeah
cause you're very you're anti-veal
so yeah i don't mind [ __ ] just
walking up to a cow and blowing its
brains out
that i don't that's part of nature
somebody got you that's all right
but to stick him in a [ __ ] cage like
and
so they can't move so the meat's more
tender to just
torture it like that you know right
yeah i mean that it's it's unnecessary
it already tastes delicious
it's doing the [ __ ] job it's filling
up my belly you know
let it walk around can you let it walk
around
um whatever
and then we had the ribs we had the ribs
and uh with his [ __ ] uh his
his rub and the mop and it was just it
was the [ __ ] and then we had the mini
apple pies
baked by you yep and then they oh my
little pie face
yeah and then uh we got the best
compliment
we heard people next to us whispering
going see look they're doing it right
they got pies
and you're like that's right
[ __ ] i know who brings
individual
pies we used to be there i used to back
in the day when i used to go to the
patriots games when i had season tickets
in 1989
we used to [ __ ] show up with a keg of
beer and a bag of chips
and we'd be sitting there look at those
people they're doing it right we just
get absolutely annihilated i could be
here
and that i swear to god that's that's
that's accurate
we would we would have a half barrel we
had a half barrel of beer
and we would be doing keg stands because
we were morons
literally like counting one two three
doing that [ __ ]
as all these adults were looking at us
like some were
repulsed and then there was other people
who did that when they were our age so
they were just sitting there with half a
smirk
probably betting which one of us was
going to puke first yeah
i did one time puking after a keg stand
is the most refreshing way ever to puke
i've never done a keg stand before
it's so it's so cold when it comes back
out usually when you're what does it
mean exactly well i guess a keg stand
usually is you're supposed to do like
somebody holds you up upside down oh
literally
okay what's the point of being upside
down is that you get more [ __ ] up that
way because you're all disoriented no
upside down it's one of those things
where you're young and you think if
i'm drinking beer i'm crazy i'm away
from my parents
what could make this crazier what if i
did it
upside down yeah it's stupid okay it's
just suburban
douchery yeah so i actually never did
that uh
we did a more adult version of keg stand
which is basically
you just [ __ ] you turn the tap on and
you just you and we were timing it
it was like the olympic trials of beer
drinking and
and as you puked you were out or if you
just tapped out like you can't do it
you'd start off with 10 seconds
and it was completely inaccurate people
just be going one two
three four four five right all the way
up to ten
if you made it to ten you were in the
next round and it went up to twenty then
it went up to thirty then went up to
forty and you gotta think you've already
drank for ten seconds ain't dragged for
twenty that's thirty seconds
now i drink for 30 now you drink 60 and
it just keeps going and going and going
and we got all the way up one time where
i was trying to beat this guy and i
and i didn't have a reputation for being
able to drink and i just went to this
[ __ ] zone
and i went head-to-head with this guy
and i just kept making
it was like the cinderella team going
through march madness
and somehow i made it i made the
championship game it was me
against this other guy who had like a
[ __ ] iron stomach
and um
i ended up i i ended up losing is what i
did but it was one of the great pukes of
my life because it was just ice cold
it was like reverse drinking a glass of
water
nice cold glass you know when you puke
it's like a city and it's it
tears up your throat yeah it wasn't
huh it was just like it just came out
was this in high school
i know i was well i think i was in my my
fifth year at college by then
no year of college i was 21 when i did
that
oh okay so i should have been a junior
but i was still a freshman
yeah i drank beer in high school
only because i don't drink beer now as
you know because i don't like the taste
of it
but i drank it in high school because
you know that's what you drink oh that's
my running joke with you i just go i
think you'd like this one and i always
make sure it's
the most hoppy yeah it's always
disgusting it's so rude
you know how much i don't like beer i
just but yeah i used i would drink it in
high school because that's what
people were drinking when you would
drink in high school but then i got onto
the uh the boons farm there you know
that cheap
little strawberry wine and wine coolers
what is it called
boone's farm it's a kind of um wine it's
like really sweet
really cheap yeah you get it at like the
gas station we would say
we would send in hangover we yeah we
would send in you know like one of the
cuter girls um to go in there and just
kind of like smile and just walk up with
you know a couple bottles of the boons
farm and you know
the 19 year old or whatever kid behind
her would just let her buy it and not
check her id
because she's hot and she's cute right
yeah exactly exactly exactly yeah
why is that a bad thing everybody i mean
it isn't jealous i'm not i'm not i'm not
condoning that because i was never
i'm jealous but i would i would say
but i always hated it but i just did it
because that's what you did
you know i'm jealous of that is what it
is guys
you know on a certain level you [ __ ]
resent that
because we don't have the option of
being hot and cute and just getting
something just coming like hot tea
i'd like a case of beer playing with
your non-existent pigtail
or maybe your steven seagal ponytail
just sort of twisting it around
it is a weird visual um let's read some
[ __ ] emails for the week
um pakistani cricket fan
he said all right man this isn't this is
important
first podcast of 2003 right
all right sorry about that i [ __ ] that
thing up i didn't delete last week so i
got to get a memory card that has a
little more
memory on it anyways
[Music]
oh jesus what is this now what is this
all right it's just gone off the rails
here all right
pakistani cricket fan starting over
again all right man this is important
first podcast of 2013 right this is
about cricket the sport
don't you stop here now come on and bear
with me
okay so pakistan and india just had a
cricket series
now these two guys they don't like each
other right why don't they like each
other i don't
know i'll be completely honest you just
got caught you were like
right i thought you like you knew the
answer no i don't i don't i'm i'm not
i'm not well versed in that i admit all
right it's not my strength it's the
usual [ __ ]
they live near each other all right
familiarity breeds contempt
and they they fight over cashmere
don't remember a few years ago they were
like i'm gonna [ __ ] nuke you
and the other guy's like go ahead and do
it we got the bomb too
you don't remember that no maybe that
was a movie i saw
anyway so pakistan and india just had a
qriket series we are arch rivals
and [ __ ] not only in cricket but in
everything i mean we had the biggest
tank wars and [ __ ] did you
they should make a movie about that and
have like tan white people play you guys
and then you guys can get offended
um so india had this these [ __ ]
commercials in which
the voice said pakistan is coming to
india
and their [ __ ] cricket player oh we're
like
oh he's saying that i thought they were
saying i thought they were saying that
in a commercial i was like
wow no this this gentleman is
he's using it all right i'm sorry i'm
sorry okay okay in which the voice said
pakistan is coming to india
and then their uh cricket player were
like
let them come now these indian [ __ ]
are the last world cup champions and
we're ready to [ __ ] pakistan in the ass
get what happened guess what happened
they got [ __ ] big time
now everything else in pakistan is [ __ ]
as you must know
just do this man
well this guy you know he is writing in
a second language here just do this man
and be on my [ __ ] side all right as i
approach
you first all right come on man just
tell these individuals read these things
first before you just start reading now
that's that's what makes it good
just tell these indian [ __ ] how bad
their cricket team sucks
and they can eat a dick and some other
clever [ __ ]
that you say he wants you to trash india
wait because he's pakistani and they
have a cricket
feud as well please rape them
please rape them yeah sir don't use that
word like that
oh you know what you don't understand
sports how'd you like that oh my god
huh you thought you were going to beat
pakistan oh we're the defending [ __ ]
uh
champions with our fraternity paddles
hitting that racquetball around the
circular field well guess what
you're [ __ ] lost you would think
considering all you guys have 18
[ __ ] kids you could find a couple of
jordans in there
right you could repeat oh well
you know what i think next year pakistan
you guys should play again
and winner takes all of kashmir
what do you think about that and you get
all the other sides tanks
there you go how was that was that all
right it yeah you're like all right cool
this is bill burr this was bill bird
trashing that's right
anybody else if you watch obscure sports
i'll
in you guys win a game i'll talk trash
about the other [ __ ] person not
knowing anything about i don't even know
i don't even get the game
i like you know what i like about
cricket though is how long
it is you know when you drink there's
there's certain sports that you're just
going to love
you just it's cricket a game that people
like drink at
like that it doesn't seem like it seems
like more civilized than that for some
reason
why i don't know why because it's
foreign
wow and they wear like all white they
just
look like spiffier i don't know they
just look like they're some sort of
class element are you thinking about
polo no don't they wear all white
i don't know pull up pull up an image of
people playing cricket i'm pretty sure
you [ __ ] pull it up i'm not your
secretary everyone wears white
well you have the laptop in front of you
right that's a good point no listen
this is this is why of course they drink
they probably have they probably have
hooligans
you said they're saying you think it's
sophisticated after what this guy wrote
[ __ ]
[ __ ] rape that's all that's one that's
all in there it isn't
that's crickets fans for you no that's
not qriket fans you know what that is
that's sports fans
that's sports fans we're morons yeah but
i think that more like like something
like a rugby i feel like has more of a
hooliganism
attached to it you know something you
would think that
for some reason i feel like cricket is
more like oh hello
you know what we're going into the creek
have you ever met a professional boxer
or one of those ufc guys i guess so if
you meet
them most of them guess so yeah most of
them they're really just
mellow kind of they don't need to prove
anything
right you know what i mean mm-hmm maybe
it's the fans so
we're not talking about the rugby
players maybe the fans are more i don't
know
i i you know i have no idea i can tell
you right now
i would keep my [ __ ] mouth shut if i
ever went to any sort of sporting event
in another country
unless you know when i go to canada it's
hockey i know hockey's back by the way
i'm really excited that it's back great
all's forgiven i don't give a [ __ ] i
i've accepted it that it's a part of
hockey
every [ __ ] five six years i have no
idea what you're talking about i know
you don't
i said all's forgiven what's forgiven
the strike they went on strike
oh you noticed you've been able to watch
way more
real housewives this time this year you
notice i'm watching way more hoop
than i've somehow in a [ __ ] secretive
way become a knicks fan
because they never show the celtics
because we stink so they're always
showing the knicks and i just i'd love
their team
okay i [ __ ] love their team did you
see that
j.r smith's that donkey head on that
alley-oop where the guy threw it too low
and he caught it down by his nuts and
just with one hand just [ __ ] through
it it was one of the most vicious things
i've ever seen
even probably as vicious as that baboon
snapping that wrestler's neck
back in the 50s um all right
innocent deer and headlights hey bill
love the show
i'll start from the beginning but i'll
be quick
you know people you know i can't read so
let's just get right to the [ __ ]
point
yeah did you did you ever read aloud in
class i hated it
yay
trying to count ahead how many people
and then try to guess which paragraph
and i always start looking over it
before he got to it
you know when i was in the fourth grade
one time i had to read out loud
and i got in my head and i was like
going like i'll just read the first
couple sentences the way i did it i was
like love
the show i'll start from
the beginning and
i finished it and i finished it i wasn't
baby
i wasn't i was in fourth grade i should
have been able to read
[ __ ] bill so when i finished reading
the paragraph the teacher went like
before you know i was like i was so
[ __ ] relieved that it was over
and i was just waiting for her to call
on the girl sitting behind me for her
you know
jennifer i read the next paragraph and
when i finished
there was this silence
and then the teacher said i didn't
understand one word he said
oh did anybody else understand what he
said oh no
nobody said anything she made me go back
and re-read it
i was like love love the show like
choking back tears
i'll start from the beginning that's
back in the 70s when you could be mean
to people
oh that's terrible is it me or is he too
[ __ ] stupid
to be in this grade you poor thing
that's not nice
it's not nice it's [ __ ] hilarious i
stunk at it and she called me out on and
i deserved it
what i should have done was viewed it as
a challenge and gone home
and just walked around the house reading
out loud well you're in fourth grade
your
brain doesn't work like that listen
you're never
too young to start manning up
instead i accepted defeat and i i
i don't know i never got that two things
happened to me that year that were
[ __ ] brutal
they had the reading out loud and
getting trashed for it
and then they did this thing called was
it called uh
sound spelling okay
you know you learn how to read in first
grade yeah
you progress in the second grade you
learn how to spell and all that
all that [ __ ] first second third okay
it's still
fresh in your head don't take it out of
the oven
it's still all doughy so you know what
these [ __ ] idiots do
they introduce sound spelling in the
fourth grade
and it's basically uh i guess phonetic
spelling
is what it probably proper name like
where you spell cat k-a-t
and they started going through all of
these words that i just learned how to
spell
within the last couple of months to
couple of years and they started putting
k's where there was seas
and all this [ __ ] and i never recovered
never recovered
why would they do that though why would
they because somebody
i don't get it they thought that it
would help with something
why would they why would they do that
why would they put fluoride and
toothpaste
why would they do that when it slows
your brain down it makes you just kind
of you know hey man
dreams aren't coming true but i'm all
right look at these white teeth you know
i don't know i don't know what i'm
talking about ever just know that know
that about this podcast i don't know
what i'm talking about ever
the monday morning podcast that's your
tag that's it all right
innocent deer in the headlights all
right push away that fourth grade
i know no it's good do you want me to
read it for you
hey if that guy who played darth vader's
voice can get over stuttering
i can do this all right hey bill love
this show
i'll start from the beginning but i'll
be quick i'm about to graduate college i
met a lady
in one of my classes we talked
throughout the semester
oh dude how many times was the moment to
get her number coming and going and you
were like [ __ ]
um and on the last day of class she
offered me her number
there it is she was probably rolling her
eyes the whole semester like for the
love of god
do i gotta drop to my knees
[Laughter]
um where the hell am i
she came up to i know oh oh billy
oh billy i met on class
we talked where the [ __ ] was i
i thought she's having a flashback right
now
did i just make that part up i can't
find it i met a girl in one of my class
we talked throughout the semester last
day class she asked me a number
i thought she was pretty cool and went
and went out with her
later that week she came up no she came
and met me
she came and met up with me god this is
[ __ ] torture
just read it
oh my god she came and met up with me
and my friends at a bar
things went well and we end up going
back to my place oh geez
we start fooling around on the couch and
then she gets up and guides me into my
room
i was getting nervous because i haven't
been with many girls
and not entirely sure what to do in this
situation
um she strips naked
and while we are sitting on my bed she
opens her legs to reveal
a white string coming out of her
ladiness
guys with the gross details here
i wasn't really sure what it was at the
time oh this guy's he's a [ __ ]
he's like that he's like that little fat
rabbit sitting outside the uh the
apartment complex
he didn't know what it was well maybe he
was just so disoriented that he
just was like what is that there's no
there's nothing
in a guy's upbringing that says uh you
know
tells you about the rip cord you know
that's just something you just learned
it's one of the few things like you know
back in the day you're supposed to learn
about like the whole reproductive system
like
it's literally like half an hour not
even half an hour maybe
a 10 minute part of your lesson about
the reproductive system when they if
they if you
okay they didn't have that they didn't
have that when i was growing up but i
can guarantee you in those classes they
never say
hey and if you're ever trying to bang
some chick who's on the rag
right right of course if you see that
little string coming out uh that me
i mean you're trying to bang a girl and
turns out she's on the rack you know
why but the thing is she knows she's
having her period so why is she well
read you know what she's going to do
she's going to want to either she's
going to want to bang
and say it's not a heavy flow day or
she's going to take it in
oh yeah that's that that could be all
right let's just this is getting gross
this is like really
graphic this is very graphic because i
wasn't really sure
what it was at the time i would have
loved
if you said what you thought it might be
she flossing down there um i told her
exactly
what i was thinking and he said this is
what he said this is classic
he sees she said that naked with a leg
spread he goes
there's a white thing dot dot dot
there
[Laughter]
she told me that it was a tan tampon
yeah
and that she was on her period she said
it was fine and still wanted to have sex
i got really weirded out not grossed out
i got really weirded out so i told her
that maybe we should wait
she told me there are other ways i
called it
i was still or maybe even further
freaked out by this girl
so we just went to sleep keep in mind
that this
this is the first night we ever hung out
yeah why did you let her stay there
did i do the right thing should i meet
up with her again or is she crazy
i don't i don't understand thanks a lot
and go [ __ ] yourself what huh
i'm confused did i do the right thing by
not sleeping with her yeah
by not having anal sex with her is that
or whatever or just
plowing through the [ __ ] storm if he
didn't feel comfortable
if he didn't feel comfortable with it
then you shouldn't have sex oh just
picture the right thing
a captain on a ship they're just going
through the waves
captain you're crazy we're gonna make it
your [ __ ]
um sorry you put that word in my head
who did that [ __ ] guy over there i
never say the f word
i say [ __ ] i don't say [ __ ]
i've tried to take it out they they told
me to knock it off and i'm trying
i respect it you you do i knock it off
so i say all right yeah you know yeah
i'm not trying to be a dick here
but for the longest time you called
somebody a [ __ ] it had nothing to do
it just meant you were a [ __ ] we didn't
know what we were saying i know yeah you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we get it we get it i'm just saying
so anyways
[Laughter]
bill bird trying to knock it off
i'm trying the thing is you're so
sometimes you're so i don't know if
innocent's the right word but sometimes
you are you're so dumb
you're so yeah you're so dumb about the
like the offensiveness that you grew up
with
you're always like what everybody said
you're so defensive about it for so long
yeah but you know something cause it's
like you honestly don't know any better
because
yeah you're dumb and then finally enough
people explain it to you
that you are a human being you have a
heart and you are sensitive so you're
like oh
okay all right i won't say anymore jesus
[ __ ] christ
like that's the attitude you have about
it
it's like you want to be a good person
but you're like
you're angry that you have to like let
go of this part of your past where
people just said
[ __ ] to each other and it was like hey
that's what we say
it's boston go [ __ ] yourself
well you know jimmy dore the great jimmy
dore i actually did a show
uh um friday night he's so goddamn funny
he has the funniest [ __ ]
bit on that on knock it off
why that's a dumb ad campaign because it
really
is like you know hey knock it out it's
really like this parental
i i don't know i don't saying oh that's
gay or
stuff like that yeah he's not saying
that that's wrong
right to try and get people to stop
doing it but is that the best way
to get people to stop doing it by saying
hey knock it off
like you're driving the car and you're
their parent you're swinging at their
leg
i don't want to step on his bit here go
go see jimmy dore and request that bit
um so anyway this young man is saying
that i do the right thing by
not sleeping with her and should i see
her again because
absolutely 100 did if she wanted to have
straight up vaginal sex there was not a
condom thick enough
or all-encompassing that would have to
take up like it would you'd have to put
it on like
underwear that condom and boxer
underwear and it'd have to all be
rubber you'd have to put on basically a
wetsuit
that had like a little flappy thing
there for your dick
so you did the right thing yeah he would
not have felt comfortable having sex
with this girl while she he if he
already was thrown off by the fact that
she had a tampon in
if you know this girl is a pig why is
she a pig
because don't defend her just because
she's a woman i'm and i'm asking a
question i'm i'm defending this why is
she a pig
she's painting from her private parts
yeah and just
it's just like let's [ __ ] have at it
that is some [ __ ]
truck stop large marge [ __ ] all right
give me a [ __ ] break i'm not trashing
all women women this woman here
is a pig he probably
no protection okay could have gone in
the back door with this girl
first [ __ ] date she's a pig so what
usually you feel like she wasn't
ladylike and respecting herself enough
or something this is what i'm thinking
exactly
you ever see the club everybody wants to
go to when there's that long line down
the street
yeah that's what has been lining up to
her her [ __ ]
private parts have you ever heard of the
term [ __ ] shaming
have you heard this term that people is
this something well that's one i've
never used so i don't need to knock that
off i've never heard that
knock it off but have you heard of [ __ ]
shaming which is basically no but i
can't i can
i can guess what it is how come if a guy
does it or guys it's done
but if a woman does it she's a [ __ ]
right exactly and that's the truest
thing you'll ever [ __ ] read
okay what is the truest thing that if a
woman does it she is a [ __ ]
so you believe in that whole double
standard absolutely why is that exactly
because you there's there's no skill
involved with you guys getting laid
all you have to do hey so this is a
skill based thing and when defined skill
the skills that you feel like you're
presenting and you're getting laid as a
guy
tell me all about your amazing skills
are you done
are you done yeah for now
yeah we've already had this argument yes
we talked about it in a bar one time
and i said okay let's turn the tables
all right
let's pretend that i'm holding the
[ __ ] bag of gold
and you're coming and trying to get it
okay hit on me come
come you know do it right now right do
it right now
i can't give myself thank you i'm not
i'm not good at it i'm not going to
you know why why because it's a skill
when women sit there and they go oh my
god guys come up to me and they say that
dumb
stuff all that's all you have to say is
a guy oh yeah what would you say
go ahead dazzle me come with me with
your hey baby what's your sign
[ __ ] line what do you got convince me
hey
uh exactly exactly
we have to convince you on stage earlier
tonight and i thought you were pretty
funny
oh thanks
yeah and i'll be i'll be and i'll be the
girl who's going to deliberately make it
difficult
i'm not good at it yeah i'm not good at
hitting on people that's not my
and you know why that is because you
didn't have to all i did was put on a
spaghetti strap dress and be like ooh
did i drop a napkin
and you're in the game flirting i can do
but that's different that's more like
conversational but no i'm not gonna just
walk you have to understand that as a
guy
you have to convince a woman to have sex
with you and after you've convinced her
you have to continue convincing her all
the way back to the apartment you got to
keep the plate spinning and
any little [ __ ] thing can throw it
off okay so because of
because of that whole struggle that you
poor men have to do
in order to get a woman to sleep with
you i think that's so bad for you
can you so because there is that
difference then just no respect
and then i'm supposed to respect it that
makes it okay
to say if a girl is like hey let's just
you know i want to have fun with you
let's let's have sex
all of a sudden she's a [ __ ] or a pig
and all that and the guy is like what
the hero or the more skilled of the two
of them it doesn't make any sense
are you done nia
first [ __ ] date she's sitting there
okay she wants to have sex whatever but
you're sitting there with a [ __ ]
bloody rag hanging out of you
and you don't even know this guy and
you're just [ __ ] spreading your
[ __ ] legs
and he's like uh yeah there's a thing
hanging out of there and she says
there's other ways i guarantee you you
know what that girl is
that's the girl when you take out the
condom who goes ah
god i hate condoms that [ __ ] girl
you you ever girl ever says god i hate
condoms
immediately run the other direction go
in the bathroom
rub one out get that dumb idea out of
your [ __ ] vice versa if a guy ever
says god i hate condoms run the other
way too
exactly just to keep it fair no you're
right no no you're right
you're so into women's issues right now
you can't see the trees through the
forest this girl is a [ __ ] pig
no i mean i no i definitely you're right
a girl
who's got a tampon and who's spreading
her legs and being like hey
and the guy's like uh are you on your
what's going on there and she's like hey
there's other ways
i mean i got any friends like
i guess there's like smoother ways to i
don't yeah this guy
this guy i would never do that i admit
that but i'm not
necessarily throwing all bad judgment
behind this girl because maybe she was
just drunk and she was probably like oh
[ __ ]
this kid is a babe in the woods right he
could have been
at this point with her after his first
class
okay he hasn't been with a lot of girls
he
basically is like do you ever see that
video of those guys who put
put a goat in a uh in a [ __ ] cage
with a python
and it doesn't even know it was horrible
they didn't think that the goat didn't
even know what it was
the [ __ ] snake's like oh [ __ ] yeah
and what literally left and like
licked the [ __ ] pythons face kind of
freaked the thing out like whoa what was
that
and then all of a sudden by the time it
realizes what it's in the cage with
it's [ __ ] over so it's terrible so
this guy is the goat and this girl is a
snake
and he doesn't realize what he's in and
just by doubting the snake
by dumb luck by dumb luck she went to
strike and he [ __ ] shook it
like [ __ ] mayweather this is turning
into a parable
the goat and the snake well all right so
basically clearly this girl is a little
too
is on a different level than this guy
and perhaps he should
maybe find a girl that's who this girl
probably is at some point in life is
going to have the std
fun pack you know what's what's included
in that fun pack though uh
little herps little gonorrhea
probably some crabs the starter kit okay
the starter kit you know before you move
on to the more serious [ __ ] like
aids ebola herbs is forever so
that's pretty intense i would think that
sounds like an advertising campaign for
herpes forever
but don't they have like they have like
that medicine you could take and keep it
at bay
uh yeah that's what they say in the
commercials like and if you have an
outbreak
take more or whatever i don't know i
don't know what they tell you to do yeah
that commercial is just scary and it's
just like you know
just because you've taken this and you
don't have an outbreak doesn't mean you
can't spread it
right you know i'm happy that makes me
feel to be with you
that we don't have the herp but we don't
have the herp
i don't have to worry about that it's
forever right
those things when i was single they
scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of me
and i remember then i hear stuff like
even if you wear a condom that's not 100
i was just oh my god yeah
well yeah she's on my fingers she's
she's uh
this is not it doesn't seem like this is
the girl for you she might be a little
too
advanced will you stop alligator armani
this might not be the girl for you she's
a little too advanced this woman is a
[ __ ] war pig
you're a data arming it i'm not i'm
trying to be like tender and
you know nice you know what alligator
armor means you don't watch sports
no i don't you know what i really don't
appreciate
when i come down here and having this
conversation with you and you want to
throw these little sports things at me
and you always
you always say oh you don't watch sports
or you get the sports thing like you
have to like remind me
that i'm not on the same level as you
like so i'm not going to get
all your amazing sports references and
terms and phrases
and i don't appreciate that can you guys
believe
that within 10 minutes of just going on
this rant about how dumb i am and how
innocent i am with using the word
[ __ ] and i i don't you have like an
innocent heart but you're dumb
and you're you just respond with rage
the whole way you made me this [ __ ]
like simpleton yeah you'd be doing
everything but [ __ ] you know
being a big goof like hey what are you
doing like walking down the street like
you know and accidentally crushed
somebody to death trying to hug them
that's how you just painted me you're
like yeah you're like of a
mice and men yeah that's how you're
painting me within 10 minutes of this
you're a lenny and of mice and men
that's how you get that's exactly how
you described me
i was too dumb to know that [ __ ]
reference
and then because i i say alligator arm
is
okay you've seen an alligator right yeah
do they have long arms no they do not
they do not and it's basic
it's a it's a sports term um
somebody throws you the ball and you
could actually reach out and get it but
you don't totally reach out because
you're worried about getting hit
okay sort of so you alligator arm it's
like
so and if you don't catch the ball the
guy can't hit you oh okay
i thought so i'm saying yo so your
alligator arm in this in that you're
going
this girl isn't the girl for you but
blah blah blah he's in
he's he's in there with the [ __ ] pit
viper right he's the goat
and she's the people he is he is the std
free
goat and he is walking into a [ __ ]
incubator of just
i mean i mean this girl probably
i don't i i want to get into a she's not
the girl for you she's not the girl for
you
that's bad advice why this girl
i'm telling you it's a [ __ ] pig and
whatever she's supposed to do about it
tell the whole [ __ ] school i'm just
no
she's not the girl for you move on to
somebody else who's more your speed why
is that bad advice
because you're acting like you know
she's
not into sports likes to eat and is a
morning person
and he likes sports and staying up you
know what
this person isn't like you know this
person isn't for you
i mean it's like a foodie it's like like
it's a simple
way of saying that that you know you
should move on that's that's all it is
no it's like you're sitting there with
the toddler and he's about ready to
touch
a hot stove you got to be like there has
to be a sense of urgency here
like like no no no no no this this will
hurt you
this will hurt you know you make the
little [ __ ] can they don't even speak
english you're trying to [ __ ]
speak english they can't they can't
speak yet you're trying to [ __ ]
go [ __ ] yourself you're sitting there
talking to this person like um
hey try some of this sandwich yeah i
didn't really like that bread well maybe
you like this bread like
it's just like this whimsical there's
too many daisies and what you're saying
this is this is a very dangerous
situation this guy should stay away from
this girl
on all [ __ ] and all girls like this
she's got a she's on her period and she
has no [ __ ] like
like class she just opens her leg
like what was he supposed to do pull it
out and just go off on it there's other
ways she's suggesting anal this girl is
like
she's a [ __ ] mess stay away from this
girl this girl will get pregnant this
girl will give you [ __ ] a disease
this girl will steal your laptop this
girl's a [ __ ] nightmare
knock it off all right all right advice
for a lady
dear bill i've been with my boyfriend
for two years now
we're in college together and he's
currently taking a semester abroad
oh jesus where in brazil
before he left we had a running joke
that i was going to need a vibrator when
he left
as a surprise parting gift he got me one
i have a couple friends whose boyfriends
bought them sex
toys so while i was a little surprised
he actually got me a vibrator
i also happen to know that it's a
relatively normal
it's relatively normal for a boyfriend
to do that yeah that's basically like
this era's chastity belt
you know you're trying to lock down the
[ __ ]
that's disgusting hey yeah but that's
what he's doing though
anyway yeah but it's done because those
things you use them too much they numb
up your area there and then the guy
can't even remotely try and
you know
do something for and then you got to be
sitting there banging them as their user
using the thing as you know it's like
you and an alien are [ __ ] this girl
is this an alien
that's just all dick it has no body
all right whatever let's move on what am
i basing it on based on my my [ __ ]
life
i did live a little bit of a life before
i met you i realized that
all right anyway fast forward to about a
week ago
we were on skype oh he asked you to take
this thing out
um no we don't have sex chats thank god
and he casually asked me
how his gift for me was working out i
told him it was working out pretty well
he then mentioned that he had bought
something for himself
a fleshlight
joe rogan experience is brought to you
by the fleshlight every week
those are very weird those are very
[ __ ] okay they look like that thing
boba fett
fell into when he died in one of those
space movies
okay wow um i know you're trying to be
faithful to her that's nice
okay he said she goes i knew what this
was because i am an average listener of
joe rogan's podcast
there you go joe rogan's come up three
times in this podcast
who raves about it constantly my
boyfriend had never mentioned to me
that he was interested in anything like
that and i always thought the idea
of it was totally creepy i acted like it
was totally cool but in all honesty
i really don't want him to be [ __ ] a
perfect
fake wait i got lost in that
i actually was thinking is joe going to
get mad that i'm saying that this is
weird
okay i acted like it was totally cool
but in all honesty i really don't want
him to be [ __ ] a perfect
fake vagina whenever he wants to i'm
finding myself getting crazy
jealous and angry whenever i think about
it
i know i know i'm jealous of an
inanimate object
which seems insane let me finish i'm
really struggling with this be
because part of me wants to be
completely okay with it
since it's sort of a hypocrite it's sort
of hypocritical to get angry when he got
me a vibrator
but now i'm starting to think that maybe
he only bought me a dildo
so i wouldn't be able to complain when
he got himself a proxy [ __ ]
roxy [ __ ] so what do you think do i
need to suck it up and get over this
or is my jealousy legitimate thanks and
go [ __ ] yourself
that's hilarious oh let him go [ __ ] his
fake [ __ ] as long as he's not faking a
real [ __ ] i mean
[ __ ] a real [ __ ] then you know it's
all good
plus you you it's not just like the
the [ __ ] that it's that he's missing
he's also missing like
you know your touch and kissing and the
whole other part of it too
and that fake [ __ ] can't blow him
either no he isn't he's getting right to
the dessert
don't be jealous have you tried these
brussels sprouts don't need them
don't be jealous bring over the tres
leche when he comes back
it'll be even better because you both
have been like doing it with inanimate
objects and so
it's like you'll be rediscovering each
other all over again it'll be even
better i don't think so don't even worry
i don't think it's a good thing
why because uh
once you start down a path sexually
you know in order to get off that path
you don't just jump over onto another
path you got to walk all the way back
up the path you went down get to the
fork where you [ __ ] up and then head
down the other one
what i'm saying is he might get used to
just
doing that and the sensation of that
is what gets him off and then when her
[ __ ] doesn't feel like the fleshlight
he'll it'll feel better he'll bang her
and then and then when he needs to
finish she'll be like all right and now
for me
with that [ __ ] thing no no she'll
feel
even better if anything he'll be like oh
my god i forgot what a real woman
feels like and he'll be done in like two
minutes that's what you hope
um i don't think she should be jealous
of it though they're both
they're both doing the right thing when
you're in a relationship and you're that
far apart from each other
because i bang all sorts of hairy
european girls no offense to hair
european girls but
i'm just saying you know listen i i
watched this
thing one time i listened to it on the
radio uh one of those
call in sex shows and this guy
had a way he jerked off because he
dry-humped the rug
it was causing like chafing on his dick
in him but it it was the only way he
could get off because he wasn't in a
relationship for a while and he kept
doing that
and i don't know so i'm just saying like
i would go easy on those
it's like anything anything in
moderation yeah how how often is he
using this
and how often is she using that if you
use a vibrator too much you numb
yourself up down there and then when
your guys down there
you can't feel anything that's so
disgusting
um overrated underrated for the week
overrated the super bowl
underrated rounds one and two of the nfl
playoffs bill this may be sacrilegious
to say in america but i actually
enjoy rounds one and two of the nfl
playoffs
more than the super bowl that isn't
sacri-religious because at no point does
beyonce or britney spears
sing before and in the halftime show
there's not a bunch of douchebags who
don't like football showing up
feeling like they have to be there you
know
all the broads why are you yeah why are
you looking at me because
you go to super bowl parties every year
and you hate football
yeah well they're fun they're nice
gatherings and they talk when the game's
on
i like no i don't build run
when the most important game is on it's
disgusting
if you do it again this year we're
breaking up each week
you get two games both on saturday and
sunday
there seems to be that we can win this
thing excitement in the air
and i can relax and watch the games in
the comfort of my home
or a local bar without dozens of
non-fans in the room
as is typically the case at a super bowl
party super bowl on the other hand has
become so pretentious in recent years
i don't even really want to get worked
up for it as much as i used to
the game takes forever 85 of the
commercial sucks
and we're forced to stare at madonna's
beat up face for 30 minutes during a
halftime show
plus the two-week gap in between the
super bowl and the conference champion
really takes the air out of the sales
what are your thoughts i think this is
what you do you watch the super bowl
alone
and you tape it and you start watching
it you dvr
it and you watch you let you let you
give the game a 90 minute head start
and then then you just sit down you
watch it by yourself
and you you plow through the pre-game
and you just watch the [ __ ] game and
when the halftime show comes you fast
forward through that
and now you're into the third quarter
and third quarter and fourth quarter
it's going to be regular time football
that's the way to watch the super bowl
and you watch it by yourself
maybe with another buddy of yours who
that uh enjoys the game that's how i
would do it
you know no thoughts on that no but what
about the
social aspects shut up we were gonna
have
brownies during the opening yeah
oh my god the way the broads talk during
that [ __ ] game and then now and then
and it's true and then everybody shuts
up to watch the commercials
and then and then the game comes back on
the uh i thought that one was lame
what did you think well that's
definitely the best one so far
how much did that cost well why don't
you stop going
to super bowl parties then bill why
don't you
stop if you don't like the game i don't
do any of that stuff that you're talking
about i don't hey i don't like
needlepoint i don't go to your [ __ ]
needle points i parties
i don't do anything what do you do arts
and crafts i don't crash your super bowl
or those things
and come there and talk when you're
trying to glue the popsicle sticks
together
and then shut the [ __ ] up when i don't
talk throughout the game i go in the
other room
or i hang out with other people if
there's live slides lies yeah
okay that's the monday morning podcast
oh before i get out of here
huh that's it that's it we did a nice
long one all right there's nothing else
huh no okay um amazon.com everybody if
you want to
um if you want to uh buy something on
amazon.com and support my podcast go to
billboard.com click on the podcast page
take it we got a link um whatever you
call it the little box a little window
thing the little uh
little icon you click on that thing i
have no idea what they're called
the banner ad you click on it you go to
amazon.com you buy something they kick
me back a little bit of money i take ten
percent of that and i throw it to the
wounded warriors project
you sponsor this and the wounded
warriors see
that's it everybody that's the podcast
for this week go [ __ ] yourselves and uh
yeah you ever get with a girl and she
spreads a leg with the rip cord there
all right you're the goat she's the
snake get the [ __ ] out of the cage
you